[Musik]
Leonardo Dicaprio Zanger und Katy Perry
Reality
Fausta Kim Kardashian und Philadelphia
Referendum Diesel-Impfstoff von Cott
auf dem verdammten Hashtag Stop Hate for Profit
von Instagram und Facebook, um Medien zu
posten Das soziale Dilemma Ich möchte
, dass die Leute wissen, dass sie
alles sind  online zu tun wird
beobachtet wird verfolgt
wird gemessen jede einzelne Aktion, die
Sie ausführen,
wird genau überwacht und aufgezeichnet
,
welches Bild Sie anhalten und betrachten, wie
lange Sie es betrachten, oh ja, im Ernst
, wie lange Sie es betrachten
mal schneller als die
wahrheit wir werden mit gerüchten bombardiert
wenn jeder das recht auf seine eigenen
fakten hat es ist wirklich kein grund für menschen
zusammenzukommen es gibt wirklich
keinen bedarf für menschen sich zu verständigen
wir haben weniger kontrolle darüber wer wir sind und
was wir wirklich glauben
Sie